Well,
I've been interested in writing online
for some time.
I was
an early participant in salons table
talk,
which was their forum,
the section in 96 97 um,
because I just thought it was
interesting that the readers could be
published in the same space as the
writers.
That idea was intoxicating to me.
And then I spent some time at Howard
Rheingold site mindstorms cause I wanted
to check out a different environment for
writing online.
But I didn't know anything about
blogging because both those sites were
produced by people who kind of new code.
I didn't really know about blogging
until a student in one of my classes in
2002 told me about it and he said,
professor rose and this is really up
your alley.
And he described his blog,
which wasn't opinion block.
He was a conservative undergraduate at
Nyu,
obviously I minority,
but he found in his opinion blog away to
make connections and the and have a
voice.
Right.
And he started telling me sort of how
the blogging system worked.
And I remember he said,
if you get a link from a big blog,
you can get lots of readers.
So I said,
well,
how many?
You said five 10,000 and I found this
staggering because the leading quarterly
journals in my scholarly field,
if that wasn't the kind of writer I was,
wanted to be our like three thousand
four thousand readers.
Right?
And He's already telling me that his
opinion blog can get five or 10
overnight.
So I didn't really understand what a
blog was,
but it's very interesting what he was
telling me.
So he told me to go check out his blog
and insta pundit.com
so I was very intrigued by what he had
told me.
And I started walking back to my office.
By the time I got close to my office,
that was closer to a running because I
just had this sense that I wanted to
know what it was.
And I remember logging in and looking at
instant money and I didn't understand
what it was because I was looking at the
surface of the blog without
understanding the blog is fear behind
it.
But once I did everything that I had
been kind of wrestling with since table
talk and mindstorms,
I realized it's here.
This is the thing,
self publishing is here.
That's a long revolution.
Self publishing,
that's a 300 year event,
right?
It's to the point where the capital
required to be a publisher has gone down
almost to zero.
That's a 300 year event,
you know,
like a 500 year flood,
so media time,
that's like a thousand year flood.
So I took a year to study blogging from
2002 to 2003 and the reasons I wanted to
do it,
we're about five.
The main one was I wanted to have my own
magazine with no editor to tell me what
a valid idea about the press and media
was.
I wanted to completely evade the
existing editorial system because
frankly it had kept me in a very limited
state of expression for a long time.
There's only so much that I could say if
I wanted to publish a Columbia
journalism review article,
if I wanted to write in a hot bed for
the Los Angeles Times,
which I did.
And it was just the frustration with the
limited range of,
of terms and the,
the very stunted imaginary of the press
about itself was the main reason I
wanted to have a blog,
which I conceived of as my own one
person magazine,
which is still my description of what
press thing is.
So I wanted to go around the gatekeepers
and I wanted to know what was happening
in this field because I was pretty sure
as soon as I understood the self
publishing is here,
that it was going to have major
consequences for professional
journalism.
So I wanted to know it.
I also wanted to catch up to,
as it were,
where my students were,
right.
And this student was a little bit ahead
of,
of the crowd,
but he was definitely pointing me
towards something that would connect me
to my students.
And um,
and I wanted
a platform to address both professional
journalist.
So I've been talking to for a while and
my earlier work and this new class of
potential journalist that I saw a rising
up also,
um,
I have a phd.
I did my dissertation on the whole idea
of the public as this thing on the
receiving and of the press.
That was what my research was about.
So when I say this is a 300 year of men,
it comes out of that because what
blogging means is that the self
publishing public is real.
You know,
a lead and said,
freedom of the press belongs to those
who own one.
Well,
what I said was blogging means anyone
can own one.
That was exciting.
That was something I had to be in on.
And I knew by the end of that afternoon,
I would have to have a blog.